[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend die
Debatte um die Lieferung von Tauros
Marschflugkörpern an die Ukraine nimmt
Fahrt auf und folgt dabei einen
vertrauten Muster anfangs wiegelte die
Bundesregierung ja erstmal ab das stehen
nicht zur Debatte die Debatte geht dann
aber weiter schließlich heißt es aus
Kanzleramt und Verteidigungsministerium
es werde keine deutschen Alleingänge
geben präziser wäre aber wohl zu sagen
nicht ohne die Amerikaner denn die
Waffen und die ist jetzt geht
Marschflugkörper mit größerer Reichweite
werden bereits von Briten und Franzosen
geliefert allein wäre Deutschland also
nicht aber aus Berliner Sicht sitzt der
entscheidende Player nicht den London
oder Paris sondern in Washington Andreas
ukrainischen Militärs der Taurus kepd
350 ein luft-
abgeworfen von Kampfjets kann Taurus
dann selbstständig Ziele in bis zu 500
Kilometer Entfernung bekämpfen 600 Stück
hat die Bundeswehr auf Lager 300 davon
sind gefechtsbereit
ein hochmodernes Waffensystem das ist
der Ukraine auch ermöglichen würde
russisches Territorium anzugreifen die
Union hatte schon früh darauf gedrängt
auch solche Waffensysteme zu liefern
wenn wir wollen dass die Ukraine ihre
Gebiete befreit und nicht Millionen
Menschen das Vertrauen in die
ukrainische Führung verlieren und das
Land verlassen sollten wir der
ukrainischen Führung vertrauen dass sie
den Auflagen gemäß Taurus richtig
einsetzt Putin Schicksal ist mit der
Krim verknüpft und mit Taurus ließe sich
die Krim befallen in dem die russischen
Versorgungslinien dort zerstört werden
noch Züge die Bundesregierung vor allem
die SPD tut sich schwer mit Taurus doch
jetzt gibt's Bewegung unter Bedingungen
wir bedenken die möglichen
eskalationsrisiken da haben wir in den
letzten Monaten hinzugelernt deshalb
können wir mit entsprechenden
Vorkehrungen auch moderne Waffensysteme
an die Ukraine die von vorausgesetzt sie
setzt sie nicht auf russischem Gebiet
ein in den vergangenen Wochen haben wir
gesehen dass wir uns auf solche Zusagen
der Ukraine verlassen können
auch ohne den Taurus geht die deutsche
Unterstützung mit militärischem Gerät
für die Ukraine weiter heute erst wurden
zwei weitere patriot-abschussrampen für
die Luftverteidigung übergeben außerdem
erteilte die Bundesregierung die
Genehmigung für die Instandsetzung und
Ausfuhr von 25 ausgemusterten Leopard 1
Kampfpanzern sowie fünf Bergepanzer die
Liste mit deutschen militärischem Gerät
für die Ukraine ist lang vom Kampfpanzer
über Munition LKW Wolldecken Schlafsäcke
bis hin zu Feld Lazaretten allein für
dieses Jahr gibt das ein Volumen in Höhe
von 5,4 Milliarden Euro eine Menge Geld
ich glaube dass wir den Menschen
erklären müssen dass es erstens
natürlich um das Leben der Ukrainerin
Ukraine geht das aber diese Angriff
Russlands auch mit uns etwas zu tun hat
wenn Russland Erfolg haben wird oder
sollte bei diesem völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriff dann wird das nicht der letzte
Krieg in Europa sein und wenn wir in
Frieden und Freiheit in Zukunft leben
wollen müssen wir jetzt und heute
nachdem wir es oft versäumt haben der
Ukraine unterstützen
ungeachtet der Diskussionen über Taurus
über Waffenlieferungen und die Kosten
wird in der Ukraine gekämpft die Russen
vermelden Geländegewinne die Ukrainer
sprechen ihrerseits von Erfolg was
stimmt ist nicht unabhängig zu ermitteln
nur eins ist sicher der Krieg geht
unvermindert weiter
für die westlichen Unterstützer ist es
ein Dilemma einerseits wollen sie nicht
das Russland auf seinem eigenen
Territorium direkt mit NATO Waffen
attackiert wird
andererseits sieht man im besten
natürlich auch was das für die Ukraine
bedeutet das Russland aus sicherer
Entfernung quasi unbehelligt ukrainische
Städte bombardieren kann und dabei
selbstverständlich auch Raketen und
Marschflugkörper mit langer Reichweite
einsetzt
aber auch beim Nahkampf mit der
Artillerie befürchtet die Ukraine ins
Hintertreffen zu geraten etwa beim
munitions-
[Musik]
Ska läuft schlecht letzte Woche wurde
das Einkaufszentrum nebenan von
russischer Artillerie getroffen zum
zweiten Mal schon
vorkommen dass ich eine Woche lang nicht
hier bin bis ich mich in den Griff
bekomme aber dann komme ich zurück zu
Hause bleiben nützt nichts es kann auch
zu Hause passieren draußen stehen
provisorische Schutzräume wie an so
vielen Orten in ressen fast wie
Bushaltestellen
jeden Tag und jede Nacht gibt es bei uns
hier Explosionen immer irgendwo
es ist schwer aber was können wir tun
nur einige wenige sind im Zentrum der
Stadt unterwegs vor dem Krieg haben hier
mal 300.000 Menschen gewohnt geblieben
sind noch 45.000 so wie Irina mit ihren
drei kleinen Kindern
ich habe ihn beigebracht was Sie tun
müssen wenn es sehr laut ist wir haben
unsere Sachen parat wenn was ist dann
sind wir zusammen ich will Ihnen
folgendes sagen wenn alle auswandern wer
wird das alles wieder aufbauen damit
unsere Kinder hierher zurückkommen
können
Leben in Hassan das ist ein Leben in
dauerndem Ausnahmezustand auch für
Polina zum Abschied fällt sie mir
spontan um den Hals
auch die andere Flussseite gehört zum
Regierungsbezirk hassson dort stehen
nach wie vor die Russen zehntausende
Ukrainer Leben unter Besatzung
dampfsituation
dort ist schwierig die Russen geben
weiterhin zwangspässe für die Menschen
aus und üben Druck auf die aus die eine
pro-okrainische Position vertreten dazu
gehört Folter sie werden verschleppt und
gefoltert
die russische Besatzung der Stadt
überlebt zeigt uns Ihr Haus das nach der
Zerstörung des kachowka-damms bis zum
ersten Stock unter Wasser stand immer
wieder ist heftiges Artilleriefeuer zu
hören weit weg
wir hoffen auf den Sieg und nicht nur
auf den Frieden auf den Sieg Frieden und
Sieg das ist nicht immer das selbe nur
der Sieg zählt eure aus dem Blumenladen
ist das skeptischer wir werden lange
darauf warten müssen obwohl wir es uns
so sehr wünschen trotzdem will sie
bleiben Herr Sonn sagt sie das ist
Heimat
nach Einschätzung von Russland Kennern
und von Russen die selbst der Opposition
angehören sowie von
Meinungsforschungsinstituten die nicht
im Auftrag Putins Arbeiten wird dieser
Krieg von einem ganz erheblichen Teil
der russischen Bevölkerung mitgetragen
angefangen mit der Sichtweise dass die
Ukraine gar keine eigenen Nation sei und
die Ukrainer nur eine Art klein Russen
bis hin zu der von der Staatspropaganda
verbreiteten Täter opferumkehr das
Russland hier einen tapferen Kampf gegen
böse Mächte führe so wie einst die
Sowjetunion gegen Hitler Deutschland
diese Perspektive findet sich selbst bei
jedem Russen die den Wahnsinn dieses
Krieges am eigenen Leib erfahren haben
und das sind bislang ja fast
ausschließlich Soldaten und nicht
Zivilisten
Urlaubsstimmung obwohl das Land im Krieg
ist an der russischen Ostseeküste
schaffen sie das ist es
Teilnahmslosigkeit oder die Flucht vor
einer unsicheren Zukunft den
Repressionen den Folgen des Krieges die
oft nicht mehr zu übersehen sind
am Strand von Biburg nahe der finnischen
Grenze treffe ich eine Gruppe russischer
Soldaten auf Genesungsurlaub
sie alle haben in der Ostukraine
gekämpft
was ist passiert
was passiert ist eine Drohne ist über
meinem Kopf explodiert Helm und
Schädeldecke wurden durchschlagen
hier sehen sie ein Opfer vom
Raketensystem heimers
wegen der Heimat hatte ich zwölf
gebrochene Rippen wenn ich wieder gesund
bin gehe ich zurück egal ob sie mich
wertauglich Stempeln oder nicht dort
gibt es so viele verwundete deswegen
muss ich auf jeden Fall zurück
Sarah teilt Moskaus geopolitische Ziele
nicht will weder dafür kämpfen noch
sterben mehrere Wochen verbrachte der
Schmied im Wald als die
mobilisierungswelle letzten Herbst
losging er fühlt sich isoliert mit
seiner kritischen Haltung die meisten
würden einfach mit dem Strom schwimmen
das sei tief im russischen Volk
verankert
in Russland haben die Menschen
schreckliche Angst auf der äußeren Ebene
ist es die Angst vor Instabilität und
vor einer schwebenden Ungewissheit auf
einer tieferen Ebene ist es die Angst
vor der zivilen Verantwortung
deswegen bekäme ein starker Führer vom
Volk viel Zuspruch mein Sava egal welche
Richtung der einschlägt die
Zukunftsprognosen des 34-Jährigen für
Russland sind düster
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten entweder es
bewegt sich auf eine vollständige totale
Abschottung und Loslösung von der
Außenwelt zu wie Nordkorea oder es kommt
zum völligen Zerfall aber niemand weiß
wie das passiert und wann
die verwundeten Soldaten geben sich
selbstsicher
Russland wird siegen anders kann es
nicht sein bald werden wir unsere Flagge
in Kiefer
wann
sehr bald wenn Europa sich nicht
beruhigt marschieren wir weiter dann
hissen wir unsere Flagge auch in Berlin
so war es 1945 so wird es 2025 wieder
sein
radikale Überzeugungen kriegsrückkehrer
die getötet haben und Sterben sahen sie
treffen auf Ausflügler Familien im
Feierabend und gehören mittlerweile fest
zu Russlands Alltag
diese Begegnungen am russischen Strand
sind Teil einer ausführlichen Doku diese
gleich im Anschluss an das heute schon
mal sehen können unter dem Titel macht
Poker an der Ostsee von Lotsen Fischern
und Düsenjets Beobachtungen unserer
Reporter im Ostseeraum von Deutschland
bis St Petersburg
mit dem Krieg einhergehen auch noch
intensivere Spionagetätigkeiten das
Deutschland dabei besonders in Moskau
Fokus steht ist nicht neu hat aber
dadurch noch mal eine neue Dynamik
bekommen die für die Spionageabwehr
zuständigen deutschen Dienste dürften
alle Hände voll zu tun haben gestern
wurde ja ein neuer Fall bekannt wie der
jetzt der aktuelle Stand ist berichtet
Frank Buchwald
das Haus sieht geheimnisvoll aus und
steckt auch voller Geheimnisse das
Beschaffungsamt der Bundeswehr in
Koblenz alles was die Truppe braucht
wird hier besorgt vom Helden bis zum
Hubschrauber ausgerechnet hier ein Spion
ein schwerwiegender Verdacht
der Tatvorwurf begründet sich darauf
dass mutmaßlich der Beschuldigte
mehrfach Kontakt mit dem Generalkonsulat
der Russischen Föderation aufgenommen
hat hat im Rahmen dieser Kontaktversuche
geheimes Material übergeben der
Beschuldigte Thomas H ein Hauptmann der
Bundeswehr tätig im Beschaffungswesen
mit Zugang wohl auch zu geheimen
Dokumenten
ein Mann um die 50 jemand der einen
aufstiegsberuf gewählt hat früher einmal
unteroffizierbar der sich also
angestrengt hat aber offensichtlich
nicht zufrieden ist was den Mann dazu
trieb mit russischen Vertretungen
Kontakt aufzunehmen und wie es heißt
geheimpapiere zu übergeben bisher nicht
bekannt
hier geht es um den gravierenden Vorwurf
des Landesverrats und Geheimnis Verrats
wer für die Bundeswehr oder eine
wichtige Sicherheitsbehörde in
Deutschland arbeitet darf nicht
Geheimnisse ausplaudern verkaufen
verraten das ist eine schwere Straftat
und die muss auch bestraft werden der
Fall erinnert an den ex-bnb Mann Karsten
l entarnt im Dezember letzten Jahres er
hatte offenbar versucht geheime
Informationen über die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte zu beschaffen die Bedrohung
durch russische Spionage nimmt zu auch
für Deutschland wir haben es mit
hybrider Kriegsführung zu tun wenn Sie
so wollen das Schlachtfeld reicht von
Afrika bis in den Cyberspace und geht
über die Ukraine hinaus bis nach
Deutschland es ist alarmierend
alarmierend weil wir eben viele solcher
Fälle in den letzten Monaten hatten und
es zeigt dass im Bereich der Spionage
und
illige Team Einflussnahme wir eigentlich
in den des Kalten Krieges wieder
angekommen sind der mutmaßliche Spion im
Bundesamt für Ausrüstung und
Informationstechnik der Bundeswehr
Thomas H sitzt mittlerweile in
Untersuchungshaft die Frage aber bleibt
wie viele andere Agenten sind immer noch
aktiv bei der Bundeswehr und anderswo
und dann wäre da ja auch noch China über
die Absichten und auch
Spionagetätigkeiten der Volksrepublik
macht man sich in den westlichen
Hauptstädten nicht weniger Gedanken als
über Russland mit dem Thema geht es
jetzt bei dir weiter Hans angesichts der
zunehmenden Spannungen zwischen den USA
und China will Präsident beiden
bestimmte amerikanische Investitionen in
sensible Technologien in China
beschränken oder untersagen er
unterzeichnete einen entsprechendes
Dekret des Bereiche wie Halbleiter oder
künstliche Intelligenz betrifft ein
Regierungsvertreter in Washington sagte
man wolle China daran hindern sich die
fortschrittlichsten Technologien zu
beschaffen um militärische
Modernisierung voranzutreiben und die
nationale Sicherheit der USA zu
untergraben
in Iran sind fünf inhaftierte
US-Amerikaner die auch die iranische
Staatsbürgerschaft haben aus einem
Gefängnis in Teheran freigelassen und
unter Hausarrest gestellt worden die
US-Regierung sprach von einem
ermutigenden Schritt es stünden jedoch
weitere schwierige Verhandlungen bevor
um die 5 zurück in die Heimat zu holen
Iran inhaftiert immer wieder Menschen
mit ausländischer Staatsbürgerschaft
unter dem Vorwurf der Spionage oder
andere Verstöße gegen die nationale
Sicherheit auch mehrere deutsche sind
inhaftiert
kurz vor der Präsidentschaftswahl in
Ecuador ist einer der Kandidaten bei
einem Attentat getötet worden der
investigativ-journalist und Abgeordnete
via visencio wurde am Mittwochabend nach
einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung auf dem Weg
zu seinem Auto erschossen der amtierende
Präsident laso verhängte einen
60-tägigen Ausnahmezustand die Wahlen
sollen dennoch wie geplant am 20 August
stattfinden
auch zwei Wochen nachdem im Niger das
Militär die Macht übernommen hat ist
unklar wie es dort weitergeht die
westafrikanische Staatengemeinschaft
ecovas beschloss bei einem Gipfeltreffen
eine Eingreiftruppe aufzustellen die in
Niger notfalls die verfassungsgemäße
Ordnung wiederherstellen soll eine
diplomatische Lösung habe aber Vorrang
Eco was verurteilte erneut den Sturz und
die Festnahme des gewählten Präsidenten
in Südkorea hat ein Tropensturm die
Küstenregionen des Landes mit starken
Regenfällen überzogen und zusätzlich
sorgte der Wind für weitere Schäden
Bäume stürzten um Straßen wurden
überflutet und Häuser beschädigt bei
Böhmen mit bis zu über 100 Kilometern
pro Stunde mehr als 10.000 Menschen
mussten in Sicherheit gebracht werden
bereits am Dienstag musste wegen des
nahenden Sturms das Welt
Pfadfindertreffen mit rund 37.000
teilnehmenden geräumt werden
Meldungen über
Extremwetterereignisse und Katastrophen
gibt es im Moment ja aus vielen
Weltregionen Hawaii mag da besonders
weit weg erscheinen aber was ich auf den
Inseln dort gerade abspielt ist dann
doch erschüttert so haben auf Maui
Feuerstürme eine ganze 12.000 Einwohner
Stadt weitgehend zerstört als der Wind
drehte ging es rasend schnell dutzende
kamen ums Leben Claudia Bates
ist da noch jemand das Feuer ist schon
in der Front Street ihr müsst jetzt hier
weg
schwarze Rauchwolken türmen sich auch am
Hafen schon auf dass den Johnson
versucht zu retten wen er kann bevor er
als Letzter vom Anleger rennt
der Feuersturm kam durch die Bäume und
hat alles mit sich genommen und ich bin
einfach nur gerannt ich habe versucht
auf dem Weg noch anderen zu helfen man
muss tun was man kann
sein Lehrer Blick spricht Bände Schock
angesichts des Ausmaßes dieser brennende
Einheimische und Touristen waren völlig
überrascht es ging alles so schnell vor
allem die malerische historische Stadt
Lahaina steht überall in Flammen hier
werden auch noch viele Menschen vermisst
im Hafen brennen selbst die Boote
Menschen sind ins Meer gesprungen wurden
von der Küstenwache gerettet aber
offenbar nicht alle
im Wasser treiben immer noch Leichen
seit gestern schon wir haben Leute
rausgezogen seit gestern abend um Leben
zu retten aber wir kriegen nicht die
Hilfe die wir brauchen
oh mein Gott
alles verbrannt und verkohlt
apokalyptisch tausende Menschen sind
jetzt ohne Obdach ohne alles
Böen mit Windstärken von bis zu 130
Stundenkilometern und völlige
Trockenheit da breiteten sich die
Flammen so rasend schnell aus dass die
Rettungsdienste keine Chance hatten und
der Notruf funktioniert hier auch gar
nicht mehr
wir sind noch bei der Bewertung aber der
Wiederaufbau wird lang dauern
nichts wie weg hier zum Beispiel zum
Flughafen viel Betrieb Touristen hoffen
dass ihre Maschinen gehen dass Sie Herr
Weise bald wie möglich verlassen können
viele Flüge jedoch wurden annulliert die
Einheimischen kommen zu Tausenden zu den
Notunterkünften
das Haus meiner Mutter ist weg mein Haus
ist weg das Haus von meinem Chef ist weg
eigentlich von jedem den ich kenne alles
verloren was wir haben
und während die Feuerwehr alles tut um
der brennende Herz zu werden sitzen ein
paar Meter weiter Menschen am Strand und
versuchen zu begreifen was hier gerade
passiert
blicken wir noch mal nach Deutschland an
einem historischen Tag heute vor 75
Jahren war praktisch die Geburtsstunde
des Grundgesetzes vom 10 bis 23 August
1948 brieten Experten aus den westlichen
Besatzungszonen darüber wie es mit
diesem deutschen Staat weitergehen soll
in malerischer Umgebung auf der
Herreninsel im Chiemsee versuchte man
die Grundzüge einer Verfassung zu
entwerfen die vor allem verhindern
sollte dass ich Geschichte wiederholt
dass die Feinde der Demokratie mit
demokratischen Mitteln die Macht
übernehmen wie aktuell diese Gefahr
geblieben ist und dass er noch so gutes
Grundgesetz allein nicht genügt war beim
Festakt heute das beherrschende Thema
Stefan leifert
der Staat ist um des Menschen willen da
nicht der Mensch um des Staates Willen
die Würde der menschlichen
Persönlichkeit ist unantastbar jeder hat
das Recht seine Meinung frei und
öffentlich zu äußern und sich über die
Meinung anderer zu unterrichten
setze die hier ihren Ursprung haben dass
sie mal einen Start Formen würden Ernte
vor 75 Jahren noch niemand
der Verfassungskonvent von Herren
Chiemsee ist unter den wirklich
wichtigen Momenten in der Geschichte der
deutschen Demokratie
möglicherweise einer der unbekanntesten
dabei ist der einer der ohne Zweifel
bedeutendsten
der Prunk des Festsaals täuscht darüber
hinweg in welch düsterer Lage nach
Deutschlands Zusammenbruch der Konvent
Takte die Überfahrt zur chiemseeinsel
lässt die Abgeschiedenheit erahnen in
der die rund 30 Männer aus den
Besatzungszonen erste Gedanken für eine
Verfassung zu Papier brachten in nur
zwei Wochen entstand ein Entwurf der
schon fast das fertige Grundgesetz war
das Fundament für eine wehrhafte
Demokratie sollte es sein ein Bollwerk
gegen ein zweites Weimar 75 Jahre später
muss ich das Bollwerk gegen
Verfassungsfeinde bewähren wie nie es
sind Sorge und Mahnung die den Ton der
Feier ungewöhnlich eindringlich
bestimmen im Kampf gegen den Extremismus
gibt es eine historische Leere die sich
wie ein roter Faden durch den
Verfassungsentwurf von Herrn die die ich
finde bis heute gilt eine Demokratie
muss wehrhaft sein gegenüber ihren
Feinden niemals wieder sollen
demokratische Freiheitsrechte
missbraucht werden um Freiheit und
Demokratie abzuschaffen
auch in Deutschland sind die Demokratie
Verächter schon weit gekommen wie ein
Schatten liegt ihr erstarken auf der
Feierstunde von heute ihnen Einhalt zu
gebieten ist der Appell der heute von
Herrn Chiemsee durchs Land gehen soll
die höchste Hürde die vor den Missbrauch
demokratische Freiheit gesetzt werden
kann haben aber die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger selbst in der Hand wir können
sehr viel dafür tun und die Demokratie
zu verteidigen kein mündiger Bürger kann
sich auf mildernde Umstände herausreden
wenn er sehendes politische Kräfte
stärkt sie zur Verrohung unserer
Gesellschaft und zur Aushöhlung der
freiheitlichen Demokratie beitragen
meine Damen und
der Festakt endet mit Streichern und
Nationalhymne nicht zum Mitsingen
gedacht eigentlich doch dann schwillt
der Gesang an leise zart zerbrechlich
genau wie das was hier heute gefeiert
wird
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter mit dem Blick auf die Wirtschaft
in den Tarifverhandlungen bei der
Lufthansa meldet die Gewerkschaft
Vereinigung Cockpit Zustimmung von
Seiten der Piloten für das ausgehandelte
Paket gut 65% der stimmberechtigten
Mitglieder hätten mit Ja gestimmt
Stefanie Barrett ist das nun tatsächlich
der Abschluss dieser langen
Tarifverhandlungen ja denn wir erinnern
uns vergangenen September hatten sich
Lufthansa und Pilotenvereinigung Cockpit
mit Mühe und Not ja gerade mal auf eine
Zwischenlösung des Juni dieses Jahres
verständigt nun wurde in doch recht
kurzer Zeit und auch sehr harmonisch wie
zu hören war ein Gesamtpaket
ausgehandelt für Piloten und Pilotinnen
sieht die Einigung im Einzelnen drei
gestaffelte Lohnerhöhungen vor zum
ersten Dezember steigen die Gehälter um
7% und ab Januar 2025 und 20 26 jeweils
dann noch mal um weitere 5% noch in
diesem Jahr gibt es eine Einmalzahlung
von maximal 3000 € macht inklusive der
bereits ausgezahlten pauschalen unterm
Strich ein Gehalts Plus von mindestens
25% über die drei Jahre darüber hinaus
erhalten die Beschäftigten künftig
garantiert zehn freie Tage pro Monat was
ihnen mehr planbare Freizeit sichern
soll das ist ein durchaus üppiges
Tarifpaket das sich die Lufthansa aber
leisten kann denn sie verdient so gut
wie schon lange nicht mehr und steht vor
einem historisch starken Geschäftsjahr
ob es allerdings bei den üppigen
Gewinnmargen bleibt das steht in den
Sternen denn die europäischen
klimavorgaben zwingen auch
Fluggesellschaften zu hohen
Investitionen und wie sich Reisebudgets
der Verbraucher in Zukunft entwickeln
das lässt sich derzeit nur schwer
absehbar immerhin sorgt die lange
tariflaufzeit für Planungssicherheit und
Kunden müssen auch keine Streiks mehr
fürchten Stefan vielen Dank
die Jugend Erwerbslosigkeit in
Deutschland hat sich in den letzten 15
Jahren nahezu halbiert in der
Statistische Bundesamt meldet lag die
Erwerbslosenquote der 15 bis 24-Jährigen
im vergangenen Jahr bei 6,0 Prozent im
Jahr 2007 waren es noch 11,9%
zum Sport bei den
para-weltmeisterschaften im Radsport in
Glasgow gab es weitere Goldmedaillen für
das deutsche Team Marke Hausberger war
bei den Frauen im Einzelzeitfahren die
schnellste und Teamkollege Matthias
Schindler bei den Männern
da der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft startet
morgen die Viertelfinale Runde zunächst
mit der Partie Spanien gegen Niederlande
danach Japan gegen Schweden und Japan
ist das einzige Land der letzten acht
dessen Team schon mal den WM-Titel
gewonnen hat
Japan präsentiert sich bei dieser WM
bisher richtig stark drei Siege und kein
Gegentreffer in der Vorrunde dann haben
sie Norwegen im Achtelfinale souverän
gezwungen meine Spielerinnen sind
anpassungsfähig und schalten optimal von
Defensive auf Offensive um dabei sind
sie schnell und haben eine gute
Spielkontrolle eine junge Mannschaft die
auch gegen Schweden im Kollektiv
überzeugen möchte herausragendes
Mittelfeldspielerin Hinata Mia Zara die
bei diesem Turnier schon fünf Mal
getroffen hat wir sind alle fokussiert
zu gewinnen und als starke Einheit
aufzutreten so soll es auch morgen gegen
Schweden sein wir wollen den Sieg ihr
großer Traum lebt 12 Jahre nach dem
letzten Triumph den WM-Titel wieder ins
Land des Lächelns zu holen
und jetzt zum Schluss möchte ich sie
noch auf eine Doku hinweisen die um 23
Uhr läuft aber auch in der Mediathek
abrufbar ist sie trägt den Titel diese
Sendung ist kein Spiel und geht der
Frage nach inwieweit Eduard Zimmermann
der Gründungsvater von Aktenzeichen XY
ungelöst mit seiner Sendung auch
Einfluss auf die
gesellschaftspolitischen Debatten seiner
Zeiten haben und um 0.30 gibt es dann
unser heute schon Update mit einer
sanktür mir und wir melden uns morgen
schon um 21 Uhr in der Halbzeitpause vom
DFB-Pokalspiel auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend für astrofans ist dieser
August ein ganz besonderer Monat nicht
nur dass er gleich mit zwei Vollmonden
aufwartet sondern auch das ziemlich
pünktlich dazwischen der Höhepunkt der
Perseiden mit bis zu 100 Sternschnuppen
pro Stunde zu bewundern ist es ist der
Komet Swift taddl der um die Sonne saust
und dabei kleine Staub und
gesteinsteilchen verliert die Erde
kreuzt auf ihre Umlaufbahn immer im
August diese kosmische Partikelwolke die
Atmosphäre bremst die Teilchen und diese
verglühen von der Erde ausgesehen
passiert das in der Nähe des Sternbilds
Perseus daher heißen diese
Sternschnuppen Perseiden
die meisten Perseiden könnten wir in der
Nacht von Samstag auf Sonntag beobachten
wenn das Wetter mitspielt aber das tut
es nicht so wirklich und deswegen ist
die beste Nacht und die Sternschnuppen
zu beobachten wohl die kommende auch
wenn die noch relativ kühl ist bei 7 bis
15 Grad da werden sie doch meist klaren
Sternenhimmel haben viele klaren Himmel
gibt es auch morgen über Tag die Sonne
strahlt meist und nur beim
Norddeutschland ziehen einige
Wolkenfelder Weg erst am späten
Nachmittag oder Abend werden die Wolken
von westendichter bei Südwestwind die
Temperaturen steigen morgen auf 21 Grad
auf Rügen und bis 31 Grad im Breisgau
und so soll ich bleiben es nicht denn es
kommen von Südwesten kräftige Schauer
und Gewitter heran am Samstag können die
Unwetter artig sein also Gewitter die
mit hagelplatz Regen und Sturmböen
verbunden sind gewittrich und warum
geht's weiter in einen schönen Abend